what the hell is going on in numenor is
that Gandalf putting the smackdown on
some wolves and this lady looks like she
could use some vitamin D rings of Power
episode 5 is out and I'm here to answer
some of the show's biggest questions and
quickly be told how wrong I am in the
comments section I save all book and
trailer spoilers until the end of the
video so don't worry I'll warn you when
that comes up but without further Ado
make sure to hit that like And subscribe
button let's get into it we begin with
Nori teaching the stranger about the
Great harfoot Migration also known as
the wandering days at this time the
harfoot's distant ancestors of Hobbits
were a nomadic people it won't be until
the year 1601 of the third age that the
hobbits of Brie are granted permission
by King argyleb II to colonize the
region that will come to know as the
Shire there are essentially three main
stops in their seasonal migration winter
in Old Forest mid-summer in Norfolk Glen
where we saw them eating those snails
and Autumn a place called The Grove
which they're heading to now judging by
the map they're somewhere east of the
miss mountains the whole question of who
the stranger is and whether or not he's
good or bad is once again at the
Forefront of this storyline Nori
believes him to be good but as we'll see
later his unexplainable Powers call this
into question is he Sauron well I think
the show wants us to think that even
waldrake hinted that the being who came
from the sky must be the dark lord
however I'm more inclined to believe
he's one of the mayor at being sent by
the Valar to Aid in the defeat of Sauron
whether this is Gandalf or some other
wizard is yet to be known here we get
our first Glimpse at these three
interesting characters known in the
credit simply as The Nomad the ascetic
and the dweller they don't appear to be
elves judging by their ears and they are
very interested in where the stranger
has landed why would they be looking for
him my best guess is based off the name
of one of these three women of the
aesthetic which means someone who
observes severe self-discipline and
abstention from all forms of indulgence
typically for religious reasons their
outfits do look like they could be part
of some sort of religion and check out
what the aesthetic has on the back of
this plate the same exact constellation
markings The Stranger made with the
fireflies and that he also carved into a
tree I'm not convinced their followers
of Sauron just yet because typically
sauron's followers wear black of course
there are exceptions the dweller has her
hand over one of the footprints
suggesting she has some sort of power to
track or identify its owner are these
black fingers a result of using magic or
sticking her hand in the ash the Elven
orc leader Adar basts in the light of
the sun telling his orc follower that
soon it will be gone whatever Adar has
planned seems to involve blocking out
the sun likely so that his Orcs who are
vulnerable to its Rays can move about
without the use of tunnels speaking of
which he's told the tunnel is complete
but just where they have stopped and
what its purpose is is yet unknown
Bronwyn has somehow hedged her way into
being the leader of the Southland
refugees not exactly sure how this came
to be considering in episode one
everyone was giving her a side eye for
hanging out with an elf who knows maybe
she got mad street cred for killing that
orc the southlanders have a big decision
to make after being told of adar's
Demands they can either die here or
swear fealty to him well Bronwyn wants
them to stay and fight waldrig leads the
cowards to pledge allegiance to someone
he thinks is Sauron more on that in a
bit back in Newman or check out this
horse being lifted onto a ship I wonder
if that's Barrick isildor's horse he'll
later mention speaking of isildur he's
pissed at his father for not being
included on the expeditionary Force
being sent to Middle Earth isildor has
blown his chance at proving himself
after purposely getting himself kicked
out of the sea guard a job his father
had to pull strings to get him on in the
first place all these men coming with
them have either served or proven
themselves worthy and right now isildor
has done none of that at the court of
numenor farazan is berated by an Angry
Crowd pissed off about the expeditionary
Force following the likes of an elf I'm
not quite sure how we went from people
all raising their hands vowing to help
at the end of last episode to this among
those displeased is Aryan although I
think her motivations for stopping this
Expedition aren't rooted in racism
towards elves rather a love for her
family her mother is dead one of her
brothers is missing somewhere out in
Middle Earth and at the end of this
episode both her dad and other brother
are off to war so she tries to get
farazon's son who she went on a date
with last episode to convince the
chancellor to put a stop to this
hellbrandt has escaped the numenorian
jail and got himself one of those fancy
smithing Guild badges this was part of
his deal with farazon to learn the
whereabouts of Galadriel after her
Escape it's how queen regent Muriel was
able to find her at the King's Tower the
success of Muriel's Expedition hinges on
halbren's willingness to Rally the
southlanders around him and that
willingness is hanging on a thread he
doesn't want to go back to the
Southlands later giving Galadriel the
symbol of his people telling her to find
another head to Crown the the migration
is not going well the lens they're
traveling through have never been this
bare before in episode 1 we learned that
a farmer's crops were basically rotting
away likely something to do with the
Orcs taking over the land it seems this
blight is spreading farther than we
thought the harfoots are attacked by a
group of wolves hinted way back in
episode 1. luckily this stranger is
there to help using this crazy strong
slam attack which causes his hand to
Blacken it really makes me question
whether using magic drains energy from
him it's possible it could be some sort
of bruise but I've never seen something
bruise that fast I'm a doctor the men of
the expeditionary Force are untrained
against Orcs thus making Galadriel a
suitable teacher considering her
experience against them she has
thousands of years of Sword training
practice compared to a few years with
these soldiers so to me it's not that
much of a stretch that she's able to
take on five of these guys at once in
fact she ends up promoting Valen deal
who was the only one able to Nick her
there's this really interesting scene
where Hal brand picks up a sword quite
expertly and it definitely looks like
he's handled one before what else is
this guy hiding Cameron pleads with his
father to stop this expeditionary Force
why now is he deciding to side with the
elf farazan here is thinking far ahead
that if they do end up helping the
southlanders they can give them a king
who will forever be in their debt the
amount of resources they could exploit
trade routes to open and riches to earn
could make them unimaginably wealthy we
can actually see two maps here that
farazon is looking at one appears to be
that of the Southlands which will become
Mordor and the other the Sea of Belfast
to the west of the Southlands likely
where the numenoreans would land King
tar palantir sure is sounding like a
crazy old man when he was King he wanted
to re-establish an alliance with elves
to fight Sauron something that got him
exiled however when his daughter tells
him the good news that she's off to
restore that connection he tells her
there's nothing but darkness in Middle
Earth The Stranger is cooling his hand
in some some water in some sort of deep
trance suddenly his arm turns to ice and
even Nori can't escape its grasp she's
blasted away and runs off frightened by
this power now we do see this stranger
examine his hand is he scared and unsure
of his own power or has his hand fully
healed there's definitely something to
say about this ice power in fact when
Nori first stepped on those flaming
Embers where he landed she noted that
they weren't hot but cold king gilgalad
of Linden has invited Prince Duren to
discuss their Alliance but the king
actually wants to find out what the
dwarves have been up to considering
their furnaces have been burning so
bright as of late the dwarves are hiding
the discovery of mithril ore a material
lighter than silk and harder than iron
Legend says that mithril was created
when lightning ensnared a tree Atop The
Misty Mountain where an unending duel
occurred between good and evil the
lightning combined with his great
conflict sprouted down the roots
creating mithril if this legend is true
mithril is thus composed of equal parts
good and equal part evil the elves too
have a secret they need mithril if they
are to survive what's to come the king
believes the life of the Eldar is fading
from them and the only way they can
prevent diminishing into nothing is to
use the mithril to saturate every last
elf and Middle Earth for kellebrimbor
has done tests and nothing diminishes
mithril's light so elrond is put in a
tough situation does he break his
promise to Duran where he vowed not to
tell anyone of this mithril or does he
keep it and risk his people dying now
there's also this fun little way Duren
plays with the King telling him these
Stone used for their dining table is
revered amongst the dwarves saved only
for mausoleums and tombs so the king
agrees to give it to him even though
that was all [ __ ] isildor apologizes
to his friend the one he punched last
episode and pleased to him to let him
join the Expedition but even though he
lets valendir get two free hits in his
friend says only when he's found
something willing to sacrifice himself
for will he be ready so isildor with no
other recourse decides to Stow away
where he finds Chemin sabotaging the
boat in their tussle the entire ship
explodes but isildor valiantly saves the
man who blew up his ticket out of there
so why then does he lie about what
happened simple it's a lot better if
he's seen as a hero rather than a
stowaway involved in the ship's
destruction Muriel and Galadriel watched
the aftermath from up top where it's
thought the culprit was a passing
brigand with tempers flaring about this
Expedition Force ferozan recommends they
win more Hearts to their cause before
venturing off but Galadriel says they
have no time to waste every second
they're not fighting Sauron is a day
he's getting stronger the blast
destroyed two out of five ships and
Muriel decides to make her decision
tomorrow morning and how brand must be
in attendance Keller brimbor comes clean
and tells elrond that he too knew the
life of the Eldar was fading it's why
they need the help of the dwarves in the
first place without them they'd never
get that Forge completed in time a forge
that may be required to quote saturate
every last elf with this mithril
Galadriel makes one last attempt to sway
halbrand to her side it seems he was
involved in unspeakable things in order
to survive and when his people find out
what he did they'll cast him out he
vowed never to return but galatriel
tells him he won't achieve Peace by
hiding on numenor he must face his past
and in so doing achieve Redemption
waldrig and Theo's friend Rowan cut
their losses inside with a Dar but
waldrig is confused when Adar implies he
is not Sauron in fact it seems as though
waldrig must prove his loyalty by
killing Rowan Aaron deer teaches Theo
how to use a bow but Theo is more
interested in why arundir chose to stay
and fight an almost unwinnable battle
Aaron dear has been with these people
for over 79 years he knows that some of
them are good people and they deserve to
stand a chance and fight Theo believes
arandir's words and divulges to him that
mysterious blade he found back in
episode 1. to Theo's surprise Aaron dear
has seen this before carved into the
walls of ostrich as a face that looks a
lot like saurons below it a sword that
looks like Theo's blade but check out
what this blade is doing it's stabbing a
man with long hair is it just a random
person or could it be a Dar and why does
a Dar want this blade so bad according
to Aaron deer this weapon is a key used
to enslave their ancestors and is
somehow involved in making Adar a god an
Orcs claiming this land but Bronwyn has
lost faith she is ready to turn herself
in at knowing the fight is futile and
her people are destined for darkness
when they March upon the tower it will
fall and this gives erandir an idea if
you stick around for my preview section
you'll know what happens elrond tells
Duran the truth about what is to happen
to his people should they not get that
mithril endurance is willing to help but
first he must convince his father the
king back a newmanor the Expedition
begins its departure isildor has secured
himself a spot having proven his heroics
although it's only gotten him the job of
stable sweeper galagra arrives in some
kick-ass armor along with her brother's
blade halbrandt has also decided to join
as the numenoreans depart for the
Southlands now here is your trailer and
book spoiler warning where we go into
trailers and try to pick out what scenes
we haven't seen yet we won't go into all
of them rather focus on scenes that
might appear next episode here we have
Galadriel alongside halbrand telling him
whatever he did to be free of it we know
how Brent has been harboring some dark
secrets something that's really Weighing
on his mind it also appears as though
they've made it to Middle Earth here's
Nori holding an apple maybe they finally
made it to the Grove where she said
there are endless apple trees however
look at the dead apples and blighted
ground around her it seems the harfoots
will reach the Grove but find it rotting
the Expedition Force has made its way to
tier herrad and here we see waldrig's
Tavern in the background more Hal brand
here it looks as though he's picking
something up from the ground with his
spear I love this shot of isildor with
giant Fireballs in the background it
seems to be some sort of trebuchet fire
Galadriel storms into battle I wonder if
this is them taking bacteria or perhaps
a different battle alongside her is
halbrand and maybe Ellen deal to her
right Galadriel awakens in the aftermath
of some huge fiery destruction we see
her get blasted by something and what i
theorized is tierharad after their
Victory now that we know Adar had
something planned that would block out
the sun I wonder if this has something
to do with it here we see the dweller
blowing some fire followed by a leaf
that looks a lot like the ones we see in
Linden it's floating through this Cavern
at first I thought this could be the
tree gilgalod showed elrond as having
been blighted however the roots here
have this bluish tinge while the ones in
Linden really do not it almost looks
like the color of the roots with the
lightning hit that tree from their
Legend which created mithril the
cavern-like quality is similar too so
what do you think are we near the tree
in Linden is it the one from the legend
or something else entirely here's
isildor's first meeting with Galadriel
he'll be in charge of her horse so
expect the two to interact at least a
little little bit here we have Adar and
his Army Of Orcs descending upon Austin
beside him as waldrig so he may have
gone through with killing Rowan it
appears bronwyn's line that ostrith will
fall will be taken quite literally as
arendir traps the Orcs within the tower
and has it collapse on them it looks
like this is how they'll even the
playing field so that's it for this
video give it a like and let me know in
the comments what you think will happen
next thanks a lot for watching for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember stand and fight
you will die